- [Voiceover] Many economists believe
that since resources are scarce
and since human desires
cannot all be blank,
a method of blank is needed.
So, let's see.
So let's look at the first choice.
Many economists believe that
since resources are scarce.
So there's only so many resources.
We don't have an infinite
amount of resources.
And since human desires
cannot all be indulged,
a method of apportionment is needed.
That actually feels pretty good.
To indulge means to kind of allow yourself
or allow someone else
to have the pleasure,
any pleasure that they want.
And so, you can't indulge
all human desires.
That means allowing everyone
to do anything they want,
use as many resources as they want.
We cannot do that, because
we have scarce resources.
So indulge is feeling pretty good.
A method of apportionment is needed.
Well that also makes sense.
You can't indulge everybody.
You only have so many resources.
So we need some way to
split those resources,
to apportion those
resources amongst people,
and so this one actually feels,
this one is feeling pretty good,
but let's just verify,
I just used this word,
that these other choices right
over here aren't as good.
So since many economists believe
that since resources are scarce
and since human desires
cannot all be verified.
So verified means validating,
proving that someone has some desire,
so that's already feeling weird.
A method of distribution is needed.
So distribution isn't
bad for the second one,
but verifying human desires.
This one feels a little bit off.
And remember, we always want
to pick the best choice.
And so, A is definitely
a much better choice.
We're not talking about verifying,
making sure that we know
the actual human desires
and then distributing based on it.
I would rule this one right over here,
this one right over
here seems a little off.
Since human desires cannot all be usurped.
That means you're kind of ignoring them
and removing them and putting in place
different desires somehow.
A method of expropriation.
So that's kind of taking from someone.
A method of kind of
expropriation is needed.
So once again, we're not talking about
trying to usurp folks' desires
nor kind of a method of
taking things from folks.
So once again, this
one feels very strange.
And since human desires
cannot all be expressed,
a method of reparation is needed.
So it is true, not all human
desires can be expressed,
but that doesn't seem
to be a counterbalance
to the whole notion of
resources being scarce.
So this one already feels weird.
And a method of reparation.
Reparations are essentially
a payment to someone
because of injustices
that you've done to them.
And so, we're not really talking about
justice and injustice right over here.
So once again, this also feels weird
and nowhere near as good as choice A.
Since human desires
cannot all be anticipated,
that's true, a method of advertising.
So advertising, once again
we're not talking about
how do we communicate with people,
what they may or may not want,
or how do we convince people
what they may or may not want.
We're going against the idea of
hey, we only have so many resources,
and we can't give everything to everyone,
so we need some way of divvying
up those scarce resources.
So once again, the advertising
really seems a little bit off.